[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
Varsovia en Polonia a uno de los
episodios más estremecedores del
holocausto el levantamiento del gueto de
Varsovia desde 1940 los judíos de la
capital polaca y de los pueblos cercanos
fueron encerrados por los ocupantes
nazis en un Distrito del centro de
Varsovia
380.000 judíos fueron asignados Dentro
de este gueto y más de 80.000 murieron a
causa de las terribles condiciones que
reinaban en el lugar especialmente por
la hambruna el 19 de abril de 1943 las
tropas alemanas entraron en el distrito
para deportar a los últimos
sobrevivientes tras 28 Días de intensa
resistencia el levantamiento fue
Derrotado y el gueto completamente
destruido algunos sobrevivientes han
preservado la memoria del gueto hasta
nuestros días pero 80 años después que
queda de esta memoria en una colonia
gobernada por una derecha Ultra
conservadora Esta es la historia
[Música]
el 80 aniversario de levantamiento del
gueto de Varsovia es muy importante para
mí como lo es para el mundo entero
[Música]
cuando venía un oficial o un soldado
alemán
un miembro de la SS uno no sabía quién
era Era un desconocido pero cuando era
tu vecino el que no quería ayudarte uno
recuerda más eso es absolutamente humano
la cuestión de la memoria es muy difícil
cuando uno pasó por eso en carne propia
y transmitirla a la siguiente generación
tampoco es necesariamente fácil
[Música]
lo que pasó fue espantoso
es difícil de imaginar
[Música]
me llamo larisa kane y vivo en Francia
Pero nací en Polonia
donde viví durante toda la Segunda
Guerra Mundial y estuve encerrada en el
gueto de Varsovia
del que tuve suerte de escapar
la vida en el gueto no era complicada
se resume en buscar comida
incesantemente
[Música]
había mucha violencia los alemanes
podían entrar y disparar
nos moríamos de hambre en el Ghetto
nos moríamos de hambre y a los muertos
los ponían en la cera desnudos porque la
ropa era importante
y los cubrían con periódico
Yo tenía 10 años en junio de 1942 cuando
treblinka estuvo listo
los alemanes nazis organizaron esa gran
redada y deportaron a más de 300.000
personas a treblica
significaba la muerte inmediata
dijeron que las personas que trabajaban
para ellos no serían deportadas
incluso dieron certificados
mi mamá tenía que trabajar en el turno
de noche le rogué que no se fuera y se
fue y nunca volvió
[Música]
es terrible para un niño que su mamá se
vaya y nunca regrese
una organización
les pagaron a los policías que vigilaban
el muro
pusieron una escalera enorme para subir
al muro de tres metros y terminé
saltando a la nieve no me rompí nada
un amigo de mi tío Alexandre estaba ya y
me llevó a su casa
y esa noche puede comer hasta saciarme
me acuerdo hasta del menú
[Música]
se habla mucho del antisemitismo polaco
y hay que decir que fue muy dañino
es cierto denunciaron a mucha gente
pero a mí me cuidaron me acogieron me
protegieron personas que no tenían
protección y que arriesgaron sus vidas
por mí
para protegerme
[Música]
la gente suele decirme pasa la página
pasa la página no puedo pasar la página
pero yo no puedo hacer borrón y cuenta
nueva
[Música]
me gustan estas fotos porque están las
tres generaciones en el medio está mi
mamá que estuvo en el gueto de Varsovia
y nosotros estamos a su alrededor
toda la familia de mi papá y toda la
familia de mi mamá fueron exterminadas
mi mamá me contó que si un judío se
escapaba en las calles de Varsovia
inmediatamente un polaco lo denunciaba
inmediatamente no había salida
Lamentablemente eso es lo que recuerdo
pero los mismos polacos sufrieron
enormemente por la guerra
sufrieron una enorme destrucción ellos
también tuvieron millones de muertos y
para ellos es extremadamente difícil
reconocer que fueron a la vez víctimas y
victimarios
[Música]
mi mamá me dio una especie de orden de
no ir de no volver a Varsovia
no tengo a nadie ni familia a la que
visitar ni cementerio al que ir en
Varsovia
[Música]
el primero de septiembre de 1939 estalla
la Segunda Guerra Mundial En aquel
momento había tres millones y medio de
judíos en Polonia cinco años después el
90% de esos 3 millones y medio habían
sido asesinados por los alemanes y sus
Cómplices es una cifra aterradora la
mayoría de la gente se Pregunta cuánto
sobrevivieron solo el 10%, Pero dónde
están hoy la mayoría de los judíos se
fueron
el trauma del holocausto combinado con
la represión del comunismo dejaba dos
opciones irse de Polonia o renunciar al
judaísmo algunos judíos permanecieron en
Polonia pero era un grupo muy pequeño un
puñado unos pocos miles Yo diría que
unos Diez mil se quedaron en Polonia
pero tuvieron que renunciar a su
identidad judía Entonces cuántos judíos
quedaron hoy en Polonia no lo sabemos
el 99% del gueto de Varsovia fue
destruido solo un puñado de personas
sobrevivió
seguimos recordándolo lo suficiente
[Música]
hay suficientes conmemoraciones que
significa suficientes conmemoraciones
como puede haber suficientes
[Música]
más polacos deberían ser conscientes de
la importancia de participar en estas
conmemoraciones
el agente de mi círculo conoce esta
historia pero no todo el mundo la conoce
[Música]
con el gobierno actual hay un cierto
odio creciente que cada vez es más
tolerado silenciosamente
aceptan Por eso estoy aquí para luchar
contra Ese odio
[Música]
cuando veo un fragmento de los textos de
mi padre Cuando veo su foto entre esas
12 personas había otras
12 personas de 400 o 500.000 que había
en el gueto al principio y 50.000 al
final los que tuvieron la suerte de
poder dejar un texto
los que quisieron dar testimonio los que
dejaron algo es una especie de vínculo
con mi padre que después de la guerra se
volvió un hombre muy silencioso
[Música]
una de las anécdotas que encontré en las
memorias de Mi padre es que cuando un
judío lograba escapar escalar el muro o
salir de alguna manera del gueto algunas
personas los ayudaban
pero también habían extinkers o sea
desgraciados que llevaban a los judíos a
una esquina y les decían bájate los
pantalones
y si estaba circuncidado disfrutaban
entregarlo a la gestapo a cambio de una
recompensa también hubo una serie de
tráficos viles hubo Héroes hubo gente
ruin y creo que mis padres se
preguntaron como procesar todo eso
[Música]
nuestro rapus
el centro comunitario judío de Varsovia
existe desde hace diez años
era muy muy necesario porque durante
muchos años en Polonia la comunidad
judía vivió en la sombra
no podíamos vernos aquí nos sentimos
bien es un lugar para nosotros
somos una pequeña comunidad judía en
Varsovia una comunidad muy diversa no
muy grande pero muy activa
[Música]
para mí es muy importante estar aquí con
este grupo de personas
aniversario para conmemorar El
Aniversario Del levantamiento del gueto
de Varsovia de forma independiente
de las conmemoraciones oficiales
creo que el Gobierno no tiene cabida
aquí
porque utiliza los mismos mecanismos de
discriminación que antes
aquí celebramos la memoria de los que
murieron y lucharon aquí
queremos recordarlos y recordar lo que
vivieron
[Música]
los de ceremonia la cuestión con la
ceremonias es que siempre tratan de
legitimar al régimen en el poder y
Cuanto más autoritario Es un régimen
determinado Cuanto más propenso es a
utilizar el antisemitismo
más suntuosas y aparatosas son las
conmemoraciones del levantamiento del
gueto como lo fueron las de este año
en 2018 el parlamento polaco aprobó una
ley que penalizaba el debate público
sobre la responsabilidad de Polonia en
el holocausto
el Haití adopte ayuda en emitir
fue aprobada por unanimidad
tras un escándalo internacional también
fue derogada por unanimidad
pero dio sus frutos aterrorizando sobre
todo a los investigadores y finalmente
logrando que el debate público abierto
sobre el tema ya no existen Polonia
[Música]
actualmente tenemos un gobierno
revisionista y abiertamente antisemita
que está reescribiendo la historia del
holocausto
aún más de lo que ya se ha reescrito
hasta la fecha
pero también hay que decir que este es
un factor que refuerza la popularidad de
este gobierno y se basa en el
antisemitismo estructural
lo cual no quiere decir que toda la
población polaca se antisemita pero una
mayoría lo es y esta es la visión de las
cosas
[Música]
para mí lo que queda del Ghetto es el
muro pero no un muro físico no un muro
de ladrillos sino el muro indestructible
de la hostilidad y el odio
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta desde Polonia
visitamos el gueto de Varsovia el mayor
gueto judío establecido en Europa por la
Alemania nazi durante el holocausto en
el contexto de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
los testimonios de los sobrevivientes
perduran en la historia recuerde que
puede Ingresar a nuestra página web
France 24.com para ver esta emisión y
las anteriores hasta la próxima
[Música]